this guy Kevin James fighting in MMA
crazy probably then again there was a
show in which we were supposed to
believe that this guy landed that chicks
I'm just saying MMA is probably not the
craziest thing that could happen in his
world yeah there is that
[Music]
here comes the boom I really felt like
saying it like that but I did write so
when here comes the boom Kevin James
plays a biology teacher in this school
that's really going under look at the
school you're like I I've seen schools
like that they're not in good shape and
in turn all the students don't care the
teachers don't care Kevin James is like
I don't make a difference in these kids
lives so I'm just gonna sleep during the
day but then they do budget cuts and
then the music teacher is gonna lose his
job henry winkler the Fonz is going to
lose his job that's unconscionable no
matter where you're from so if they want
to keep the music program they have to
raise $40,000 the principal doesn't give
a [ __ ] but Kevin James he cares so then
he gets the bright idea hey I could
fight MMA and raise the money but then
he starts getting motivation just like I
want to win the fights he starts getting
a little bit of pride then it shows in
his teaching job and kids get motivated
they get involved and it kind of
trickles out and I loved seeing that I
love the fact that the movie does touch
on the fact that when people start
making a difference in their lives it
starts spreading like a fire and then
people around them start getting
motivated and you just see people
getting motivated and changing for the
better this movie did have quite a few
laughs in it too if you've seen Kevin
James's other movies that he's come out
with recently for the most part they're
[ __ ] and I'm not saying here comes the
boom is a masterpiece I'm just saying
it's good I mean you're rooting for
Kevin James the entire time it's really
cool to see him train they do a whole
montage scene cuz you got to have a
montage montage where it shows him
training and fighting and you enjoy
seeing the guy getting better you know
at a point it shows him training near
the end Kevin James could kick my ass
that is a fact there's watching him
you're like yeah he could fight better
than me maybe I do believe you could
land a chick from King of Queens the
tapes believable I mean there's some
useful stuff in the movie too selma
hayek
really buying what she's useless he's
realized if she was taken out of the
entire movie she nothing would be
different not for him not for us not for
anyone else in the movie Henry Winkler
was awesome though I loved Henry Winkler
like seeing people like Henry Winkler
he's such a nice guy you agree with
Kevin James you liked he can't lose his
job you really buy the fact this guy
would go through all this training all
this defeat just so this other guy can
save his job that's what I liked about
this movie also Kevin James's character
he's not doing this for him now he's
doing this for this other guy he could
have just done nothing in his world
would never have changed and he would be
none the wiser
but he goes through this quest to save
this guy's job I like saying that that
was cool so do you have to see this
movie right now right away not really
but if you do see it you can't help but
enjoy it and be like that was a
feel-good movie it was good and it gave
me quite a few laughs a lot more than a
lot of Kevin James's other movies and
that ain't bad I will say here comes the
boom is a good time no alcohol required
got me a soft spot for the feel-good
movies what can I say dude landed that
chicken King of Queens now you fight MMA
respect right so what's your favorite
underdog movie you know we're the
underdog the guy has to fight the odds
everyone loves movies like that you know
you got your favorite what is your
favorite comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]